welcome back to cbs this morning we are
hearing from bianna taylor's boyfriend
for the very first time since she was
killed by louisville police back in
march
kenneth walker is his name he was in
taylor's apartment when police barged in
with a search warrant and shot her
they were looking for drugs at the time
but did not find any
walker is suing claiming police
misconduct now none of the three
officers involved in the raid have been
charged
tarika duncan spoke to walker's attorney
about this case
tariqa good morning to you a lot of
people been wondering about kenneth
walker how is he holding up
not good gail you know he said he is
still heartbroken over the death of
brianna taylor and as you may recall
he was originally charged with attempted
murder of a police officer
because he fired one shot believing that
police that night
were intruders now that charge was
dropped but it was dismissed
without prejudice what does that mean it
means that technically
kenneth walker could be charged again
with a crime
my life changed forever in the early
morning of march 13th
kenneth walker breaking his silence
announcing his lawsuit against
kentucky's attorney general
louisville's mayor and the entire metro
police department
i was raised by a good family i am a
legal gun owner
and i would never know we shoot a police
officer walker's attorney say he was
standing his ground
under kentucky law and should be
protected from further prosecution
they also believe walker was wrongfully
charged with attempted murder
and that law enforcement officials
violated his rights
it's just more evidence of the disparate
treatment of
african americans in the criminal
justice system right
less than two hours to charge them on
march 13th
but these officers have had about six
months and they still have
a charge the night brianna taylor was
shot and killed by police
walker claims officers burst in without
announcing themselves
he says he assumed it was an intruder
and fired one
shot prompting police to fire back eight
bullets
hit brianna taylor that was a very
reasonable assumption
on kenny's behalf which is why
he after several times of asking and no
one responded he grabbed his
legal weapon last week jamarcus glover
taylor's ex-boyfriend was arrested on
drug
charges he was also arrested the night
taylor was killed by police
and was the subject of the investigation
that led police
to raid taylor's home there is no
evidence
of any drug transactions ever or any
involvement
in the drug trade at brianna taylor's
apartment
other than her ex-boyfriend visited her
there
according to this document leaked on
social media by taylor's family attorney
glover was offered a plea deal last
month in exchange for naming taylor as a
co-defendant in a drug case
the lead prosecutor thomas wein issued a
statement saying the document
was a draft that was part of
pre-indictment plea negotiations
and taylor was never a co-defendant with
glover
the prosecutor later directed taylor's
name be removed from the final plea
sheet
but her address is still listed in
connection to the case
the only thing they do show is that they
will do
anything to try to smear her in order to
justify this police shooting
walker's attorneys claim the bullet that
hit one of the officers
likely came from another officer and not
walker
they said they won't know until they see
the ballistic report
which the state's attorney general
addressed on face the nation
we do have that ballistics report we
will be meeting with the fbi at the
beginning of this upcoming week
to have a painstaking review of that
information
walker and his attorney say they will
not let up
for her and those that i love i can no
longer remain silent
one officer involved in the raid was
fired the other two were put on
administrative leave the mayor's office
says
they have not seen the lawsuit therefore
they will not comment at this time and
we're still waiting
to hear back from the kentucky attorney
general's office as well
as the louisville metro police
department
roy jerica that's an interesting
maneuver to
allegedly try to get brianna taylor
named as a co-defendant in her
ex-boyfriend's case that's
thank you very much tarika that's very
very ugly but you know the name brianna
taylor is only growing louder
calls for justice justice and her case
are only growing louder
in all avenues of life yeah a big part
of this is
qualified immunity it says doctrine in
the law that makes it harder to charge
an officer even if that officer is seen
as acting outside the guidelines of
their department so they can be fired
but not charged
but we'll see where the investigation
case isn't going away yeah
all right